Soy un veterano de la nave Enterprise.
Viajé por la galaxia,
manejando una nave gigante
con un equipo de personas de todo el mundo,
muchas razas diferentes, muchas culturas diferentes,
muchas herencias diferentes,
todas trabajando juntas.
Nuestra misión era explorar nuevos mundos extraños,
buscar vida nueva y nuevas civilizaciones,
ir audazmente a donde nadie había ido jamás.
Bien --
(Aplausos)
Soy nieto de inmigrantes japoneses,
que vinieron valientemente a Estados Unidoos, a un extraño nuevo país,
buscando nuevas oportunidades.
Mi madre nació en Sacramento, California.
Mi padre era de San Francisco.
Se conocieron y se casaron en Los Ángeles y yo nací ahí.
Tenía 4 años cuando Japón bombardeó a Pearl Harbor,
el 7 de diciembre de 1941.
De la noche a la mañana, el mundo se sumergió en una guerra mundial.
Los EE.UU. repentinamente se vieron envueltos por la histeria.
A los japoneses-estadounidenses, ciudadanos de este país de origen japonés,
nos observaban con sospecha, miedo y mucho odio,
simplemente porque nos parecíamos a quienes bombardearon Pearl Harbor.
La histeria creció y creció hasta que en febrero de 1942,
el presidente de los Estados Unidos, Franklin Delano Roosevelt,
ordenó que los japoneses-estadounidenses en la costa oeste de los EE.UU.,
fueran todos reunidos sumariamente sin cargos, sin juicio,
sin debido proceso.
El debido proceso es un pilar central de nuestro sistema judicial.
Todo eso desapareció.
Nos debían juntar y llevar a prisión
en 10 campos enrejados por alambre de púas
en los lugares más desolados de los EE.UU.
El ardiente desierto de Arizona, los sofocantes pantanos de Arkansas,
los basueros de Wyoming, Idaho, Utah, Colorado,
y dos de los lugares más despoblados de California.
El 20 de abril celebré mi cumpleaños número 5.
Y sólo unas pocas semanas después,
mis padres despertaron muy temprano a mi hermano menor,
a mi hermana bebe y a mí, y nos vistieron de prisa.
Mi hermano y yo estábamos en la sala, mirando por la ventana,
cuando vimos dos soldados acercarse a la casa.
Traían rifles con bayonetas.
Caminaron hacia el porche de la entrada, y golpearon la puerta.
Mi padre atendió y los soldados ordenaron que salieramos de la casa.
Mi padre nos dio, a mi hermano y a mí, unas pequeñas maletas para cargar.
Salimos y nos detuvimos en la entrada, esperando que mi madre saliera.
Cuando finalmente mi madre salió, tenía a mi hermana bebé en un brazo,
y una gran bolsa de lona en el otro. Corrían lágrimas por sus mejillas.
Nunca podré olvidar esa escena.
Se quedó fundida en mi memoria.
Nos sacaron de la casa y nos subieron a vagones de tren,
junto con otras familias japonesas-estadounidenses.
Había guardias vigilando a ambos lados de cada vagón,
como si fuéramos criminales.
Nos llevaron dos tercios de camino hacia el otro lado del país,
meciéndonos en ese tren por cuatro días y tres noches,
hacia los pantanos de Arkansas.
Aún recuerdo el alambre de púas que me aprisionaba.
Aún recuerdo la alta torre centinela con ametralladoras apuntándonos.
Recuerdo la luz de exploradora que me seguía
cuando tenía que salir de mi barraca a la letrina.
Pero para mí, de 5 años,
pensaba que era bueno que iluminaran el camino para guiarme.
Era un niño muy pequeño para entender las circunstancias de por qué estaba ahí.
Los niños son increíblemente adaptables.
Lo que sería grotescamente anormal se convirtió en mi normalidad,
en las prisiones de los campos de guerra.
Se convirtió en mi rutina hacer una fila tres veces al día,
para comer una comida mala en un salón ruidoso y sucio.
Se me hizo algo normal, ir con mi padre a bañarnos en duchas comunales.
Estar en una prisión, en un campo con alambre de púas,
se convirtió en mi normalidad.
Cuando la guerra terminó, nos liberaron,
y nos dieron un pasaje de ida a cualquier lugar de los EEUU.
Mis padres decidieron regresar a casa, a Los Ángeles,
pero allí no fuimos bien recibidos.
No teníamos un centavo.
Nos habían quitado todo, y la hostilidad era intensa.
Nuestra primera casa fue en Skid Row en la parte más baja de la ciudad,
viviendo con vagabundos, borrachos y locos,
con hedor a orina por todos lados, en la calle, en el callejón,
en el pasillo.
Fue una experiencia horrible,
y para nosotros los niños fue aterrorizador.
Recuerdo una ocasión, cuando un borracho se acercó tambaleándose,
se cayó justo frente a nosotros, y vomitó.
Mi hermana pequeña dijo, "Mamá, ya, vámonos a casa."
Porque para nosotros, la casa estaba detrás del alambre de púas.
Mis padres trabajaron duro para levantarse otra vez.
Habíamos perdido todo.
Estaban a la mitad de sus vidas y comenzando de nuevo.
Trabajaron hasta los huesos
y finalmente lograron reunir el capital
para comprar una casa de tres habitaciones en un buen vecindario.
Cuando era adolescente,
tenía mucha curiosidad sobre mi niñez en prisión.
Había leído libros de civismo
que me hablaban de los ideales de la democracia americana.
Todos los hombres son creados iguales, tenemos derecho inalienable a la vida,
a la libertad, y a la búsqueda de la felicidad,
y no podía encajar esto con lo que conocí con mi encarcelamiento de la infancia.
Leí libros de historia, y no encontré nada sobre esto.
Así que entablaba con mi padre, después de la cena,
largas, y en ocasiones acaloradas, conversaciones.
Tuvimos muchas, muchas discusiones.
Lo que saqué de ellas fue la sabiduría de mi padre.
Fue él quien sufrió más
bajo estas condiciones de encarcelamiento
y aún así entendía la democracia estadounidense.
Me dijo que nuestra democracia, es de la gente,
y puede ser tan grandiosa como puede ser la gente,
pero es también tan falible como lo son las personas.
Me dijo que la democracia estadounidense es vitalmente dependiente
de las buenas gentes que valoran los ideales del sistema
y se involucran activamente en el proceso de hacerla funcionar.
Me llevó a una sede de una campaña poítica
-- el gobernador de Illinois se postulaba para la presidencia --
y me mostró la política electoral.
También me habló sobre los jóvenes japoneses-estadounidenses,
durante la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
Cuando Pearl Harbor fue bombardeada,
jóvenes japoneses-estadounidenses, como todos los jóvenes,
corrieron a enlistarse como voluntarios para pelear por su país.
Ese acto de patriotismo fue contestado con una bofetada en la cara.
Se les rechazó y los rotularon como "enemigos no-extranjeros".
Era idignante que te llamaran enemigo, cuando estas ofreciéndote
a pelear por tu país.
La intención de la palabra "no-extranjero",
significaba "ciudadano" pero en forma negativa.
Incluso les quitaron el término "ciudadano",
y los encarcelaron por todo un año.
Entonces el gobierno se dio cuenta
que había una escasez de hombres por tiempos de guerra,
y tan pronto como nos juntaron,
habilitaron el servicio militar, para jóvenes japoneses-estadounidenses.
Era totalmente absurdo. Pero lo increíble, lo sorprendente, fue que miles de jóvenes
japoneses-estadounidenses, hombres y mujeres,
salieron del cercado de alambre de púas,
se pusieron el mismo uniforme que los guardias,
dejando a sus familias encarceladas, para pelear por este país.
Dijeron que iban a pelear, no solo para sacar a sus familias
de su encierro, sino también porque valoraban
que los ideales que nuestro gobierno defendía, debía ser defendido,
y que había que abolir lo que se estaba persiguiendo.
Todos los hombres son creados iguales.
Y se fueron a pelear por este país.
Los pusieron en unidades separadas para japoneses-estadounidenses,
y los enviaron a los campos de batalla de Europa.
Ellos se entregaron gustosos.
Pelearon con increíble valentía y coraje.
Los enviaron a las misiones más peligrosas
y tuvieron la tasa más elevada de bajas en combate,
de todas las unidades de esa guerra.
Hay una batalla que ilustra esto.
Fue la batalla de la Línea Gótica.
Los alemanes estaban apertrechados en la ladera de una montaña,
una ladera rocosa, con trincheras inexpugnables.
Tres batallones aliados habían estado intentando por 6 meses,
y estaban estancados.
Llamaron al 442 a sumarse a la lucha,
pero a esos soldados se les ocurrió una idea especial pero peligrosa.
La parte trasera de la montaña era un risco de roca vertical.
Los alemanes creían que un ataque por atrás sería imposible.
Los hombres del 442 decidieron hacer lo imposible.
En una noche oscura sin luna,
comenzaron a escalar esa pared de roca.
La caída sería de más de 300 metros,
con todo el equipo de combate.
Escalaron toda la noche por esa piedra vertical.
En total oscuridad, algunos perdieron el apoyo de las manos o los pies,
y cayeron al abismo hacia la muerte.
Caían en silencio.
Ni uno solo gritó, para no delatar su posición.
Esos hombres escalaron por 8 horas seguidas,
y los que llegaron a la cima, allá se quedaron hasta la primera luz del día,
y tan pronto como hubo luz, atacaron.
Sorprendieron a los alemanes,
se tomaron la montaña y rompieron la Línea Gótica.
Un estancamiento de 6 meses, roto por el 442 en 32 minutos.
Fue un acto impresionante. Cuando la guerra terminó,
el 442 regresó a los EEUU como la unidad más condecorada
de toda la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
Fueron recibidos en el jardín de la Casa Blanca
por el Presidente Truman, quien les dijo,
"Uds. pelearon no sólo contra el enemigo, sino contra los prejuicios, y ganaron.
Ellos son mis héroes.
Sostuvieron su fe en los brillantes ideales de este país,
y demostraron que ser estadounidense no es solo para algunas personas,
que la nacionalidad no se define por la raza.
Expandieron el significado de lo que es ser estadounidense,
incluyendo a los japoneses-estadounidenses,
a quienes se les temía, de quienes se sospechaba y a quienes odiaban.
Eran agentes de cambio,
y a mi me dejaron un legado.
Son mis héroes, y mi padre es mi héroe,
que entendió la democracia y me guió a hacia ella.
Ellos me dieron un legado,
y ese legado trae sus responsabilidades.
Yo estoy dedicado a hacer de mi país, un mejor EE.UU.
A hacer de nuestro gobierno, una democracia más real.
Y por los héroes que tengo, y las pruebas que hemos pasado,
puedo pararme aquí frente a ustedes, como un japonés-estadounidense gay.
Pero más allá de eso, soy un estadounidense orgulloso.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)